лікар протезист з України і підприємець
з Білорусі роблять протези для
українських військових вони створили у
США благодійну платформу протез
фондейшин яка допомагає українцям які
втратили кінцівки через війну приїхавши
в Америку я понимал что в Америку я
розумів що мені буде дуже важко стати
хірургом тут
мені сподобалося протезування я вивчився
тут закінчив Гарвардський університет за
спеціальністю протезування та
ортезування
і артизирования и закончить його я почав
працювати приблизно 15 років працює у
протезуванні і завжди у мене в серці
було бажання допомагати людям я завжди
допомагав людям з Африки Південної
Америки України
а Юрій арошедзе переїхав до США із
Білорусі кілька років тому тут від
початку повномасштабної війни в Україні
почав допомагати українським біженцям а
потім військовим
коли почалася війна звичайно усі не
могли просто так дивитися на війну Усі
хотіли щось робити як і ми Але у нас
була історія щодо війни Коли до нас
приїхав хлопець Богдан із Дніпра молодий
паспорт церкви у нього ампутація в
дитинстві відбулася він потрапив під
трамвай Він приїхав сюди жив у мене і Я
возив його до лікаря на протезування
Яків зробив йому безкоштовне
протезування так не з ним і
познайомилися потім коли почалася війна
Ми займалися нашими емігрантами
українцями які приїжджали сюди
допомагали різними способами в нас був
невеликий штаб і в один момент виникла
ідея так як ми зробили протест для
Богдана чому не можемо протезувати
допомагати солдатам нашим солдатам нашим
їхнє благодійна платформа працює
мінеаполісі з травня 2022 року проте за
вже отримали близько півсотні осіб
кілька дітей сімейна пара з Буча решта
пацієнтів військові ЗСУ саме українським
захисника надається першочергова
допомога поза чергою також діти а в
списку очікування наразі понад 700 людей
ми поділили весь проєкт на дві частини
медичну та організаційну медичною у нас
Яків займається повністю це закупівля
встановлення протезів У нас є своя
клініка з лабораторією деяків робить
протези усім за один день тобто до нас
приїжджає група солдатів вони за один
день отримують протези і Вже ввечері
ходять на протезах пацієнти проводять у
США 3,5 тижні для протезування та
реабілітації протезування однієї людини
коштує приблизно 15 тисяч доларів ми
третім всього 800 доларів Ми витрачаємо
всього 800 доларів для того щоб солдати
прилетіли сюди Але що ми маємо за ці 800
$. ми за 800 доларів маємо те що
пацієнти перебуваючи в Україні і
відлітаючи в Америку відкриваю для себе
новий світ
для них це дуже класна реабілітація те
що вони зі свого середовища сирен
вибухів та всього іншого переміщуються
сюди де є Нова країна
більшість солдатів взагалі за кордоном
ніколи не були в Америці рівень
вдячності до солдатів ви знаєте дуже
великий їм скрізь Дякую за службу не
важливо що це українські військові вони
дуже дякують підходять за них платять
усіх ресторанах куди ми не підемо за них
усі платять вони відчувають тут
величезну любов і підтримку спільноти
огромную Любовь и поддержку проєкт
об'єднав близько 150 волонтерів задіяних
У різних сферах харчування житло
транспорт а також волонтери медики
більшість їхніх пацієнтів українські
військові але є і цивільні та діти
Саша Играл на во дворе Саша гра у дворі
коли влучила ракета і осколками йому
дуже поранило ногу
він каже мене оглушило я почав бігти в
будинок
чомусь моя ніжка перестала слухати мене
це було важко чути від дитини якій жити
і жити
[музика]
А тут він втратив ногу я встановив йому
протез вище коліна Він завжди питає А
можна мені ще спортивну стопу А можна
щоб я міг бігати і ви знаєте я тепер
Саші збираю гроші щоб зробити йому
біговий протез в якому йде спеціальне
коліно спеціально стопа не просто
спортивна стопа а Бігова
протест foundation існує на
пожертвування донатець як правило велика
кількість людей невеликими сумами по
20-50 доларів засновники проєкту кажуть
щонайбільше їх захоплює мотивація
пацієнтів які хочуть якомога швидше
встати на ноги і повернутися в Україну А
що він наміння у дебіл Олег который буде
особливо мене здивував Олег з Бучі коли
був напад саме на Бучу то він постраждав
втратив руку
і я прошу його щоб він довше залишився
тут щоб я закінчив протезування
він каже як його будь ласка швидше
зробіть Я повинен їхати на мене чекає
місто нам потрібно відновлюватися у нас
техніка вкрадена У нас місто завмерло
ми маємо повернути місто до нормального
життя він може залишитися в Америці він
може залишитися в Європі У нього був
дозвіл на проживання в Іспанії Куди він
потрапив відразу після ампутації але він
хоче повернутися та допомогти Україні і
ви знаєте Я подумав тоді я маю зробити
усе максимально можливе щоб ці українці
мали бажання повернутися і продовжувати
боротися за краще Україну
[музика]